well I don't know when he's gonna
propose but you know it's coming at some
point it could come anytime though like
it Rick he could wait I don't know I'm
trying not to be a pusher because I tend
to do that okay growth all right so
you're not putting any pressure on it to
be this year yeah but like if he wants
to I'm totally okay with that well he
did I woke up today just thinking I was
gonna go tour mausoleums in a cemetery
to see if I wanted to buy one and this
and this I love you I feel like a queen
Vanderpump rules stars Stassi Schroeder
and Beau Clark are engaged I am love her
so much
I'm I feel really [ __ ] Bo
appropriately pop the question on
Wednesday at one of stassi's favorite
places the Hollywood Forever Cemetery
what is it about this woman
oh my god I can just be myself and I
like I can just legitimately I feel so
comfortable and happy and I just have
fun and he just literally just I love
him for him and he loves me for me and I
I guess I just want to be around him all
the time
and I really never had that I've never
which is kind of sad I guess but I have
it now celebrate yeah he's my best
friend
like I would legit the couple met in
August 2017 after being set up by the
other two witches of WeHo Katie and
Kristen it's really nice it's the right
fit it is it's like oh you know what I
should have listened to my friends when
they're like we want to introduce you to
who we think you should date and finally
I listen to them after 10 years and they
did and it worked out our friends seem
to think that you guys are gonna be the
next couple to put a ring on it do you
think there's no tie mine but yeah and
we know what's gonna yeah of course yeah